今から日本語のレッスンを行います。
それでは、今から日本で見たことのないもの・ことをいくつか紹介したいと思っています。
よろしくお願いします。
ゴジラ。
忍者。
正しい英語が書いてあるシャツ。
Gacktが引けない楽器。
汚いトイレ。
清潔なラーメン屋さん。
髪をマシュルームカットにしているホスト。
野生のピカチュウ。
乞食。
全粒粉のパンを売っているスーパー。
コンビニの駐車場にある車の中で、
携帯をいじっていない人。
カオス。
変に使われているタコ。
スエットパンツを履いて通学する女子大生。
番組に出てくる食事を
「まずい」
と評価する芸人。
パーマをかけた女の子の幽霊。
職場でお茶を作っている男性。
キリスト教信者。
「おっ、意外に安いな」
と思った車検の見積もり。
太ったアメリカ人くらい、
太った人。
踏み入れても良い、綺麗な芝生。
東京でドリフトをしている車。
つまり東京ドリフト。
列に無理やり割り込む人。
非対称のケーキ。
態度が大きいCAさん。
しつこくないNHKの人。
「あっ、そっか。ありがとうね！」
安いチーズ。
包装が一つしかない贈り物。
バラエティ番組の素朴なセット。
居酒屋で乾杯せずに飲む人。
「ありがとう。喉、乾いちゃった」
二つ以上のベンチプレスが置いてあるジム。
4秒以上祈っている一般人。
グレート・デーン。
古く感じないカラオケのPV。
クランプダンスを踊るジャニーズのメンバー。
努力不足が要因の失敗。
健康保険がない人。
引きこもり。
納豆パックのLサイズ。
申し訳ある人。
「あっ、」
「申し訳あります」
失礼しない人。
「あっ、」
「失礼しません」
少しでも日本のことをバカにしない外国人。